did you spot all of these moments in the
new trailer for across the spider verse
we're not horsing around here let us
point to some of the small details you
might have missed
he might be on the road to a trip across
Dimensions but before he can start on
that Journey miles still has some local
Small Time Crooks to deal with but in
classic Spider-Man fashion these happen
to be villains with exceptionally wild
Powers the walking talking bread
dispenser found stealing from a
convenience store is Jonathan own also
known as the spot this is a bad guy
covered in interdimensional Portals that
make him a nightmare for any hero in
Peter Parker The Spectacular Spider-Man
number 98 Dr Jonathan own is sucked into
a strange black portal and becomes a
super powered being called the spot that
comic marked the beginning of his career
as part of Peter Parker's Rogues Gallery
he wasn't originally an enemy of Miles
Morales but it's nothing new for the
spider-verse series to play fast and
loose with its heroes and villains in a
sequel that's already going to send
miles slipping in and out of portals
seeing him tackle someone who can create
them at will is guaranteed to spark some
fantastic sequences we can't wait to see
them
in the first movie in the spider-verse
series one thing was made abundantly
clear anyone can wear the mask
you could wear the mask
well there's a whole bunch of new masks
to spot in the sequel's second trailer
while there are plenty of returning
favorites here to catch your eye as well
as some oddballs like spider horse the
trailer also gives us our first good
look at some of miles's new allies
there's Jessica Drew also known as
Spider-Woman riding in on her bike while
bearing a baby bump there's also Hobart
Hobie Brown the spider Punk along with
pravita prabhakar otherwise known as
Spider-Man India
Jessica Drew is a storied character from
Marvel Comics but spider punk in
Spider-Man India might be a little more
obscure the guitar rocking hero spider
Punk debuted in 2014 and this version
sounds like a Londoner unlike the new
york-based Rebel from the comics
Spider-Man India is based on a
four-issue run of comics that retells
Spidey story in an Indian setting Beyond
them one of the real winning shots of
the trailer involves the appearance of
Ben Reilly the infamous Scarlet Spider
two things set Ben apart from his
contemporaries first he looks cool
sporting a stylish blue hooded vest
second in the comics he is actually a
clone of Peter Parker created by villain
Miles Warren The Jackal this means that
there is a chance that this Scarlet
Spider is actually one of two Spider-Man
from the same Dimension although Ben was
created to be a villain and replace
Peter Parker in the comics he finds
himself compelled to fight for the
forces of good before long he becomes
one of Peter's allies popping up in his
first comic in 1975 the Scarlet Spider
became a huge part of Spider-Man lore
for a time he was even considered the
main comic Spider-Man this occurred when
Norman Osborne convinced the two web
crawlers that Peter Parker was in fact
the actual clone the two then switched
places and Ben took over the mantle
thinking he was the original superhero
it will be interesting to see how the
filmmakers adapt such a complicated and
major part of Spider-Man continuity for
the world of spider-verse or if they go
there at all
facing issues like bad guys and bad
grades it's understandable why miles
would take the first chance he gets to
get away from his world and into another
or 10. as revealed by Gwen the lobby is
a creation of Miguel O'Hara a hero from
a futuristic world who was teamed up
with the best bunch of web slingers he
can find unfortunately it seems that
Miles hasn't made the list for some
reason or another you can never be part
of this don't even get me started on
Doctor Strange and a little nerd back on
earth 1999.99 now while this will no
doubt get lovers of a live-action MCU
excited about the streams Crossing it's
worth noting that the numbers don't
quite add up in regard to the Earth
mentioned here doctor strange and the
Multiverse of Madness pegs the MCU we
know as earth616 however many more
comics focused fans see the MCU as being
sent more accurately in Earth
1999.99 could this be the first step in
getting an animated Tom Holland swinging
alongside Miles Morales in the
spider-verse Anything is Possible no
the trailer sees Parker from the first
movie making a welcome reappearance as
expected he is now a proud father to a
baby girl named May swinging through the
air without a care in the world Mayday
Parker is based on Spider-Girl who
debuted in 1997 as part of a what if
story a member of the mc2 Universe an
alternative future timeline she is the
superpowered daughter of Peter Parker
given her age and Peter's brief
appearance in the trailer we wonder if
Peter will be taking a back seat this
time around with an even greater focus
on Miles even though Peter has seemingly
been accepted into O'Hara's team of web
slingers it doesn't mean he'll be the
most active member of the team he is a
father now after all and there's a high
chance that he'll only appear alongside
his former Protege in a mentor capacity
as much as miles appears to want to join
the new spider Club it seems that
there's a toll for entry that he might
not be willing to pay as explained by
Miguel O'Hara also known as Spider-Man
2099 being Spider-Man is a sacrifice you
have a choice between saving one person
and saving every world
is the seeming threat to Miles dad a
Double Bluff it could be but as any fan
of Spider-Man knows losing a family
member is inevitable with this job
closing off this eye-watering preview
there's a chunkier dose of spider versus
spider as miles and Miguel battle on
what looks like a futuristic bullet
train with other spider folk including
Peter and Gwen trailing closely behind
Peter tells Miguel that this isn't what
the futuristic crime fighter promised
suggesting that this fresh dose of power
might have gone to O'Hara's head
whatever it is he has planned though
miles isn't signing up for it in what
feels like a final battle moment that
you'd expect would be tucked away until
the film's release miles looks to be
charging up against Miguel and saying
he's going to do his own thing
the question is what kind of
ramifications could that have on all the
universes if the MCU and into the
spider-verse have taught us anything
it's that throwing things out of
interdimensional whack causes serious
problems with that in mind could the
film end with miles's actions having a
negative impact and Miguel being in the
right after all given that this is the
second part of a planned Trilogy who can
say either way our Spidey senses are
well and truly tingling
if we were to go over all the Spider-Man
suits we spotted in this trailer it
would take all day nonetheless it's
worth mentioning that one decidedly more
equine version of the character makes a
blink and you miss it appearance just
before the preview ends right as the
amusing Spidey to Spidey therapy session
gets interrupted by Miles and a giant
mass of spider people crashing through
the wall viewers can see that one of
them is actually a horse wearing a
Spider-Man mask because this is a comic
book movie we're talking about this
bizarre spider horse actually has
canonical precedent in the source
material his name is Widow and he gains
his superpowers when he is bitten by a
radioactive spider along with the wild
west inspired Patrick O'Hara AKA
webslinger widow's human partner miles
also crosses paths with these characters
in the comics even inducting them into
his web Warriors team at one point to
fight a multiversal threat could a
similar partnership form between these
characters in the movie perhaps but it
looks like this majestic beast of a
spider animal might be starting off on
the wrong foot with miles or hoof that
is in any case it's nice to see that
Widow is carrying on the spider animal
Legacy for across the spider verse it's
currently unknown whether or not John
mulaney's spider-ham will be making a
return appearance
into the spider-verse is full of great
Tunes but blackway and black caviar's
what's up danger is arguably the
standout song of the movie the official
trailer for across the spider verse
released in December also uses the song
carrying on its Legacy while two times
might be a coincidence or in this case a
handy audio callback to the greatness of
the first spider-verse movie this second
across the spider-verse trailer also
uses what's up danger so very very
prominently that the intention is clear
every major superhero either has or
would greatly benefit from an instantly
recognizable theme song this trailer
goes a long way toward establishing this
track as an Anthem for miles
if you've spent any time on the internet
at all you've almost certainly bumped
into that Meme where two 1960s cartoon
Spider-Man characters are pointing at
each other
the good people at Sony and Marvel are
well aware of the popular image to the
point that in 2022 the official
Spider-Man movie Twitter page even
recreated it with Spider-Man no way home
Stars Toby Maguire Andrew Garfield and
Tom Holland the spider-verse people are
also very familiar with the meme it
popped up in the first film as a
post-credit sequence when we got our
first look at Miguel O'Hara and the new
trailer ramps the meme up further than
you might think was even possible
the trailer devotes but a few short
seconds to the gradual escalation of the
pointing scenario and the ensuing
confusion but it's already hilarious
enough to make the viewer not so
secretly hope that the full movie will
turn it into an extended gag
[Music]